j'aurais rebondir sur ce que dit
alexandre bigot m bigot je vous dis
aujourd'hui benjamin pour la plupart ont
dit c'est vrai qu'on trouve qu'il a
merdé voilà que la vidéo est inapproprié
que c'est un manque de respect moi je
vois là je vous le dis c'est vrai que je
le dis c'est toujours très compliqué de
rire avec les religions avec les signes
religieux
j'aimerais chez moi voilà moi je lui ai
dit voilà c'est compliqué et on a le
droit au blasphème et cc c'est compliqué
on blesse énormément de jouer plus qu'on
les fait rire donc ça me dérange quand
on blesse énormément de gens juste il ya
un truc
c'est benjamin a été menacé de mort de
décapitation de chose horrible ça
franchement ça bien sûr
il faut arrêter on peut donner son avis
dire que la vidéo n'est pas drôle parce
qu'il a fait c'est pas bien que il a
déconné que voilà que ça nous fait part
hier que sa noblesse mais le menacer et
qu'il ait autant de menaces de mort et
qu'aujourd'hui sa vie soit en danger
parce que ça va être compliqué pour lui
ce soir aussi il y avait deux messages
qu'on voulait faire passer en tout cas
moi ce n'est pas passée je te lis
benjamin voilà je te le dis j'ai rien
contre toi mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas
aimé cette vidéo m'a énormément choqué
et kiki je me dis voilà je pense qu'elle
va blesser de nombreuses personnes et je
le dis avec la religion toutes les
religions il faut faire il faut faire
attention parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
aujourd'hui on a le droit au blasphème
il faut être très drôle on en parlait la
fois sur calais douvres à la fois drôle
ya des gens qui arrivent à rigoler tout
la c1 c'est un petit peu compliqué
surtout sur les réseaux ça touche
énormément de gens qui peuvent se
retrouver avec cette vidéo en pleine
gueule et qui peuvent être est choquée
maintenant
aujourd'hui il a 18 ans benjamins ils
sortent dans la rue avec la peur au
ventre il peut bien faire ce qu'il veut
plus sortir dans la rue c'est quand même
problématique aussi je suis désolé
il a fait une vidéo voilà qu'on retrouve
pour la plupart pas drôle déplacé mais
c'est pas une raison pour qu'il ne
puisse pas sortir dans la rue qui vivent
cloîtrées chez lui donc ils reçoivent
des milliers de menaces de morts je
pense que nous verrons cm sur rb ce qui
est troublant c'est qu'on a l'impression
de voir deux personnes complètement
différente c'est un jeune homme de 26
ans exception alors il a son tic toc on
voit un jeune qui est dans la provoc
c'est quand même un euro parce qu'il est
prêt à tout pour faire le buzz est ce
que cette excuse entre guillemets du
combat pour vous faire accepter en tant
que jeune homosexuel qui est très
important est-ce que c'est pas une
stratégie de communication de crise vous
dire on va passer la crise et le bad
buzz entre guillemets non pas du tout
mais quoi qu'il arrive ça il faut
toujours les foules comprend des princes
est clair que jamais une personne qu'on
voit sur les réseaux et qu'on voit sur
notre téléphone sur la même personne
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui disent
comme gainey on a l'impression qu'il a
deux visages là il a l'air tout mignon
en plateau on a envie de bien des maux
la seule intention mais quand on revoit
sur la vidéo et quand on vous voit sur
les sur la vidéo vous avez fait on se
dit oui mais ça c'est autre chose mais
parce qu'on imagine beaucoup moins qu'il
ya une vie derrière une vidéo que quand
là on me voit en j'exprime j'ai pas
qu'un second pour m'exprimer je danse
pav mais vous dites que vous dénoncez
mais on comprend pas ce que vous
dénoncez dans la vidéo s'est présenté
comme juste de la provocation alors que
là aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus clair
ce que vous de vous l'expliquer même pas
après aux gens qui vous demande sur
titeuf vous par exemple si vous
habitez en plusieurs étapes pour eux je
rentre dans votre dans votre ce que vous
dites c'est à dire vous rentrez dans
l'église vous êtes heures un plus bas à
peu sous substances vous faites ça vous
pensez pas le poster mais après il ya
une deuxième étape tiens je vais le
poster après il ya une troisième couche
c'est à dire quand on vous en parle sur
tik tok déjà en plus qui sont plutôt
pour vous qui vous aiment bien il ya une
jeune fille qui dit mais moi je suis
hyper déçu parce que je te suis je
t'aime bien et vous continuez dans cette
provocation est là aujourd'hui vous êtes
un chien savant pour moi où il ya eu une
breaking avec votre avocat qui avait
conduit entendu ces navires étaient
bloqués bloqué bloqué d'étape et en plus
vous possédez le droit d'avoir été
choqués droit d'évoquer n'attendent plus
que vous pile mais je connais même pas
je ne sais même pas comment on rentre
mois sur tik tok donc vous êtes l'âge ça
n'a rien à voir vous êtes beaucoup plus
fort en tic toc toc excusez donc vous
savez vous allez alors je vais surtout
ne prenez un empereur ne prenons pas ça
pour vous l'avez mérité tous à cette
position j'ai bien c'est que vous
possédez les codes et vous savez très
bien puisque regardez vous avez posées
j'avais jamais vu ça en jupe à marseille
vous avez déjà été menacé de mort vous
savez très bon
c'est clair daniel on pourra faire
quelque chose ça j'ai dit que déjà ça tu
parais qui peut paraître anodin et c'est
un message celui on peut le comprendre
vous avez déjà reçu des menus de man et
c'est très mal mais vous possédez ces
codes vous savez ce que vous risquez
l'homme pourquoi vous pourquoi vous
recherchez
il faut lui répondre maternalisme parce
que j'ai pas décidé de choisir la
résilience ou la soumission face à tout
ce que je me prenne dans la gueule
ça fait deux ans que je reçois des
menaces de mort ça fait deux ans que
j'ai pas dans la rue ça fait deux ans
comme celui qu'on prend en photo comme
crime dans la rue ça fait deux ans que
je suis pas bien vrai que je suis pas
serein et ça fait deux ans que je
continue à dire je suis là j'existe on
est plusieurs existait alors à près de
manière plus ou moins maladroite de
manière plus ou moins respectueuses de
la vie du lieu où aux yeux de pain de
mie mais quoi qu'il arrive ce qu'il faut
faire ou ce que vous jusqu'où prendre
tout ça là ça fait pas de moi quelqu'un
qui mérite que non mais ça mais ça fait
pas de moi non plus à une méchante
personne je suis pas une méchante
personnes je suis pas quelqu'un qui veut
du mal à qui que ce soit je suis pas
quelqu'un qui veut ramener ces qui que
ce soit de cette vidéo ces jeux je suis
pas je suis pas un méchant genre je
serai pas un méchant